[Music]
so in the last decade a handful of
people that i've worked with have never
come back from here this is extremely
dangerous
[Music]
waits glacier otherwise known as the
doomsday glacier is bigger than florida
and attached for now to the west
antarctica ice sheet which itself is
bigger than india weights is unique in
that it's melting faster than any other
glacier on earth and it's at the same
time the one we think is the most
vulnerable it has a kind of an unusual
shape in that when you start at the
coastline of antarctica at weights
and you work your way inland back to
south pole the bed underneath it to see
the seafloor becomes deeper and deeper
so as it melts there's more and more ice
to melt so it's a runaway unstable
glacier that right now might be right on
a knife's edge and may in fact pass that
point the nice edge for thwaites is when
it melts and collapses an ominous event
lurking somewhere in the future weights
does hold the possibility to
change the global coastline by something
of scale three meters say florida for
example is only has an elevation of
about three meters so we're talking
about a massive potential change on the
planet when we arrived here a couple of
weeks ago a massive iceberg some 40 by
30 miles wide blocked
our icebreaker from getting close with
weights so we're in plan b now we're
studying a glacier next to crates the
physical processes are similar so we
learn a lot by studying this one
last night
we drilled down to this ice sheet with
that tower we put a temperature sensor
down below and right now it's 500 meters
below my feet down in the waters of the
pacific ocean glaciers are losing mass
around the world the antarctic lost 51
billion tons of ice between 1992 and
2001
that amount nearly quadrupled between
2012 and 2016 to 199 billion tons the
melt is responsible for alarming sea
level rise putting thousands at risk in
the us alone nearly 30 percent of the
population lives in coastal areas what
it's all about here is collecting data
so we can do a global glacier sea level
forecast at airports around the world
there are temperature sensors and then
there's something called the weather
equation it's a mathematical equation
and that is the forecast that shows up
every day on your television or your
iphone and this is an attempt at solving
an equation that's way more difficult
a glacier equation
[Music]